here's how it starts maybe it's your
mother or maybe your sister she starts
complaining of headaches and strange
tingling Sensations in different parts
of her body her discomfort escalates she
complains of hallucinations she starts
hearing voices then the seizures begin
she has trouble walking and eating and
maintaining control of her bladder the
seizures become violent she thrashes
around her bed for hours you try to
restrain her but she suddenly has
impossible strength her moods become
erratic she swings between fear and
anger and sadness Her speech becomes
ragged and deep she's sudden Outburst
where she barks out phrases in Latin and
Aramaic languages she doesn't speak then
for no reason at all the symptoms
suddenly stop and she's back to her
normal self brightened and exhausted but
it's still her her doctor can't find
anything wrong with her psychiatrists
and neurologists can't explain what's
happening this scenario happens to
hundreds of families every year all over
the world of every different culture and
religion and when this does happen to
someone you love and there's no one else
to call you call an exorcist
born into a devoutly Catholic Family
annalize Michelle had a normal childhood
uh what kind of name is Anal ease
annalize what I say
she was kind creative and intelligent
she had good friends and she got good
grades her dream was to become a teacher
when she was 16 years old annalize
experienced a violent seizure she was
diagnosed with temporal lobe epilepsy a
neurological disorder that can cause
hallucinations and affect one's
personality over the next few years
annalize received various treatments
including Psychotherapy and
anti-convulsive medications but her
condition didn't improve her
hallucinations got worse and her
seizures more severe and when she was 21
years old annelise's condition took a
dark turn she began to experience
terrifying visions of demonic
apparitions she said she heard voices
condemning her to Hell her Catholic
upbringing led her to believe that she
was being tormented by demons and since
her Medical Treatments weren't working
she turned to her faith annalize became
obsessed with religious practices she
would pray for hours and even harm
herself trying to drive away the evil
spirits that she believed possessed her
she prayed so often that she broke the
bones in her knees but she kept praying
finally when annalize was 23 her family
turned to the church for help they
wanted a priest to perform an exorcism
over the next 10 months she would
undergo a series of 16 exorcisms these
sessions were exhausting and could last
for hours and during the sessions she
would scream growl and speak in
languages she had never learned
foreign
it's okay
she would physically harm herself
breaking her own bones and tearing her
own flesh she would attack other people
in the room she also suddenly had
superhuman strength sometimes she would
throw people across the room when five
people could no longer restrain her she
was tied to her bed when she broke her
restraints she was chained her body
deteriorated rapidly she said the demons
wouldn't allow her to eat though she
would occasionally eat spiders and bugs
crawling around her room eventually her
body couldn't take anymore and she
passed away when she was only 23 years
old she weighed less than 70 pounds and
the official cause of death was
malnutrition and dehydration in the
aftermath of her death annalize's story
became the subject of intense debate the
mainstream view is that annalize had
been the victim of a gross failure of
the medical and religious establishments
her family and the priests were actually
convicted of negligence and abuse though
they didn't serve any time and this case
was the inspiration for the film The
Exorcism of Emily Rose and now there are
lots of films about exorcism but just a
few years ago the church avoided talking
about them or denied they ever happen
but one movie would change all that and
exorcism would go mainstream
long been on the best seller lists and
directed by the man who had brought the
French Connection to the screen The
Exorcist had long been awaited widely
speculated upon and anxiously
anticipated
but no one no matter how close are
deeply involved in the film could
possibly have anticipated what was to
happen
when The Exorcist was released in 1973
it was a phenomenon people lined up for
hours to see it it ended up being one of
the highest grossing films of all time
exorcism was now mainstream and The
Exorcist is still considered one of the
scariest films of all time and one of
the reasons for this is its realism the
film is based on a novel by William
blatty but his novel is actually based
on real events bloody read about a boy
who underwent several exorcisms in 1949
and for years the boy was known as
Roland doe or sometimes Robbie Manheim
but we now know his real name was Ronald
Hunter when Ronald was 13 he was
devastated by the recent loss of his
aunt she taught him many things
including how to use a Ouija board and
not long after Zant's death Hunker
started experiencing Paranormal Activity
like knocking and scratching sounds from
behind his bedroom walls water would
drip from pipes into his room though no
leaks were found but the worst event
Ronald experienced was his bed suddenly
moving across the room Ronald's parents
called on ever every expert they could
find doctors psychiatrists psychologists
they couldn't find anything wrong out of
options their Minister suggested that
the hunklers contact an exorcist with
permission from the Catholic Church
Father e Albert performed his first
exorcism on Ronald in February of 1949
but it would be cut short even though
Ronald was strapped to his bed he broke
off a piece of his mattress spring and
slashed the priest across his shoulder a
few days later scratch marks appeared
all over Ronald's body one set of
scratches spelled the word Lewis which
Ronald's mother took as a sign to seek
help in St Louis and several more
priests and assistants tried to help
Ronald Witnesses reported seeing
scratches appear on Ronald's body and
they saw his bed move on its own more
and more scratches appeared on Ronald
and despite multiple exorcisms nothing
weren't he was getting worse he was more
aggressive and then he started urinating
on his bed and around the room finally
Ronald Hunter was admitted to the
Alexian Brothers Hospital in St Louis
and after a month of violent 10 Tantrums
of screaming and cursing Latin phrases a
priest called on Saint Michael to expel
Satan from Ronald's body seven minutes
later Ronald came out of his trance and
said he's gone Ronald humpler went on to
lead a normal life in fact he became a
NASA engineer who worked on the Apollo
and space shuttle missions his identity
was Kept Secret for years a friend said
he lived in a state of constant worry
that his co-workers would find out that
he was the boy who inspired The Exorcist
Ronald Hunker retired from NASA in 2001
and passed away peacefully in 2020 and
in the years since the movie was
released the number of possessions has
increased as has the number of exorcisms
one of the most famous and scariest
cases happened just a few years ago and
like so many stories like this it all
started with flies
in 2011 Latoya Ammons along with her
three children moved into a house on a
quiet street in Gary Indiana in December
of that year despite the Indiana cold
her Porsche was infested with black
flies no matter how many they killed
they kept coming back late one night
Latoya and her mother Rosa Campbell
heard The Stomping of footsteps climbing
up their basement stairs then the creek
of the door from the basement to the
kitchen slowly opened Latoya followed
the sound there was no one there she
locked the door and went back to bed an
hour later the sounds returned this time
Latoya saw the shadowy figure of a man
slowly walking around her kitchen again
she jumped out of bed to investigate and
again the kitchen was empty but there
were large wet boot prints on the
kitchen floor a few months later things
would escalate this time it was Latoya's
mother Rosa who was startled awake
Latoya was screaming mama Mama Rosa
followed the yelling into her
granddaughter's bedroom there was
Latoya's 12 year old daughter
unconscious Levitt rotating above her
bed the girl fell back to her bed opened
her eyes and had no memory of what
happened Latoya reached out to local
churches for help but nobody took her
seriously but a local Clairvoyant told
her the house was possessed by 200
demons and told Latoya to burn sage and
sulfur throughout the house straight
sage and suffer I don't know if that
gets rid of demons but it sure would get
rid of people yeah sulfur smells
horrible it's just it's like intense
rotten eggs tell me about it every time
you eat cabbage the resulting fumes make
my eyes water okay that's enough you
know my next contract I'm gonna add the
human shall not consume any sauerkraut
broccoli or cauliflower within 48 Hours
of doing a show anyway the Ammons house
was quiet for a few days but then things
escalated again both Latoya and Rosa
said demons possess the children then
ages 7 9 and 12. the kid's eyes bulged
evil Smiles cross their faces and their
voices got very deep every time it
happened the seven-year-old boy would
sit in a closet it and talk to another
boy that no one else could see the other
boy would describe what it's like to be
killed and once the seven-year-old flew
out of the bathroom like he'd been
thrown the 12 year old told doctors that
she sometimes feels like she's being
choked and held down where she couldn't
speak or move she then Heard a Voice say
that she'd never see her family again
and wouldn't live another 20 minutes now
for Skeptics this story might sound
far-fetched but all this information is
from official police reports written by
two veteran officers who became
Believers still no matter what you
believe the best course of action in a
situation like this is to see a doctor
and get actual medical care which the
family did and somehow in front of
medically trained Witnesses things got
even worse
it seemed that whatever demonic forces
were in Latoya Amin's house attached
themselves to her children while being
examined at their doctor's office
Latoya's Sons aged seven and nine
suddenly passed out and couldn't be
revived 9-1-1 was called and the boys
were rushed by ambulance to Methodist
Hospital when they woke up the
nine-year-old seemed okay but the
seven-year-old thrashed and screamed it
took five men to hold him down at this
point someone at the hospital thought
that this Behavior was the result of a
troubled home or that their mother
Latoya had a mental illness they called
Child Services the case was assigned to
Valerie Washington who asked the
hospital to examine the Family Hospital
Personnel found Latoya and her children
to be healthy with no physical marks or
bruises a hospital psychiatrist said
Latoya was of sound mind but when
Washington spoke to the seven-year-old
his eyes rolled back and he growled it's
time to die and then he lunged at his
brother he grabbed his brother by the
throat and refused to let go it took
several adults to pry him off and what
happened next really rattled the
hospital workers according to
Washington's official DCS report the
nine-year-old had a weird grin on his
face and then while holding Rose's hands
walked backwards up a wall into the
ceiling he then flipped over and landed
on his feet he never let go of his
grandmother's hands the boy doesn't
remember doing this and says he couldn't
do it if he tried this was witnessed by
a nurse who corroborated the event in
the DCS report and I linked all these
documents below Valerie Washington
decided that until they could figure out
what was really happening DCS should
take short-term custody of the children
meanwhile the hospital chaplain
contacted Reverend Michael magino and
asked him to interview the family and
perform an exorcism if he thought demons
were possessing them when Reverend Magno
went to the house the lights would
flicker for no reason and the blinds
started moving he also saw wet
Footprints when the Reverend showed
Latoya a crucifix she went into
convulsions he believed there were
ghosts and demons in the house which was
some kind of portal to some where
somewhere bad a week later DCS stopped
by with police officers to check the
condition of a home they found the house
to be clean quiet plenty of food oh so
aside from demons a lovely place to
raise a few kids right nothing's worse
than an inconsiderate roommate do you
mind sorry go ahead
Captain Charles Austin a 36-year veteran
of the Gary Police Department didn't
believe in demons when he entered the
house but he did by the time he left
while at the home one of the officers
audio recorders died even though it had
fresh batteries another officer recorded
audio and when he played it back later
he heard an unknown voice whisper hey
I'm surprised
the officers took photos of the house
and saw ghostly figures in the images
Captain Austin took a photo with his
phone that showed the silhouette of a
person who wasn't there Captain Austin's
police radio stopped working his garage
door stopped working the electronics in
his personal car stopped working even
though mechanically all these things
were perfectly fine and this is all
documented in an official police report
Captain Austin said he investigated some
of the most heinous crimes imaginable
but there was no way he'd spend a night
alone in that house finally Reverend
magino performed a series of exorcisms
on Latoya and the house after the third
session the house was clean Child
Services returned the children to the
home under the stipulation that there
would be no further talk of demons or
possession the strange activity stopped
and Latoya Ammons moved out of the home
about a year later and various other
tenants lived there until it was finally
purchased by Zach Bagans uh Zach who
he's the host of Ghost Adventures oh
yeah
yeah it is bro that's him he shot the
documentary demon house there and then
when he was done shooting he demolished
the house if there was a portal in the
house it's now closed and many people
said that this case is evidence of the
power of evil and the need for faith in
a war against demonic forces and if this
is a war on the other side of the planet
is the World's Greatest Warrior
[Music]
father Gabriela amorth a Catholic priest
and Exorcist could be described as a war
hero in the battle against evil but
there are more fearlessly battled
thousands of demonic forces that
threatened to harm The Souls of the
faithful and for over 30 years he was
the vatican's chief Exorcist which is a
real title of a real job in the church
well that's one hell of a business card
it sure is Father Mort performed
thousands of exorcisms over his career
and wrote several books on the subject
he believed that demonic possession was
a real phenomenon and that the devil was
actively working to destroy the faith of
Believers in the movie the Pope's
Exorcist Russell Crowe plays father
remort and the cases shown in the film
are taken directly from father Mort's
own writing the movie is part par part
Da Vinci Code and part Indiana Jones it
includes a great storyline about a
Vatican cover-up just one Vatican
cover-up what about the other ten
thousand baby steps if you're into
exorcisms or Supernatural Thrillers
definitely check it out now father amort
exercised thousands of demons from
hundreds of people during his 30 years
as Chief Exorcist now that might sound
like he's exercising everyone who walks
through the door but that couldn't be
further from the truth before someone
could even be considered for an exorcism
they're required to see a physical
doctor and a psychiatrist father remort
said that less than half of one percent
of people who contacted him are actually
possessed and he would Whittle that
number down further he had a few
techniques that allowed him to tell if
someone was truly possessed one of these
was to have the possessed person close
their eyes then he would bring a holy
object like a crucifix near them to see
if they react if they did he knew he was
dealing with a true demonic possession
no
the exorcism ritual typically takes
place in a church or other Sacred Space
and only a few people are present father
remort brings a trained assistant who
helps with prayer and occasionally helps
hold the person down a couple of the
possessed persons family and friends are
also present to assist and in 2016
father amort allowed William freaking to
film an exorcism on a young woman named
Christina there's no better choice than
freaking he directed The Exorcist
[Music]
the exorcism ritual itself is highly
structured and involves a lot of steps
that have to be done in a specific order
there's a lot of prayer the sprinkling
of holy water and the use of a crucifix
to draw out the demons the exorcism
ritual can be physically and emotionally
demanding both for the person being
exercised and for father remort and his
assistant the person may experience
convulsions and screaming as the demons
are cast out father remort we continue
the exorcism until he was confident that
the demons had been cast out of the
person's body and this could take
several hours or even multiple sessions
once the exorcism was complete father
amort we'd pray over the person and give
them a blessing and the only exorcism
father Mort allowed to be filmed turned
out to be his last he passed away a few
months later at the age of 91 but even
worse that exorcism didn't work
Christina was still possessed and
although William freekin tried to
contact her she was never heard from
again
foreign
is usually connected to the Catholic
church but the concept goes back
thousands of years to the beginning of
civilization ancient Babylonians believe
that demons or evil spirits were
responsible for illnesses as well as
natural disasters exorcism rituals were
done to drive these entities out and
restore balance to the world and the
process of exorcism in ancient Babylon
was complex and dangerous The Exorcist
would draw a circle around the possessed
person creating a barrier between them
and the demon he would then recite
special incantations and around the
circle sprinkle various substances like
salt and herbs and for especially evil
demons an animal like a goat or a
chicken would have to be sacrificed
throughout the nerves and a dead chicken
that doesn't sound like a ritual it
sounds like a delicious recipe
you're killing me pal well I'm sorry I
skipped lunch and you tell me exorcisms
use 11 herbs and spices on chicken what
do you expect
by the way you and Colonel Sanders make
demon sand Finger Licking Good that was
not my intention now I know what a
chicken's so addicting it's seasoned
with evil if you just let me get through
this we'll grab lunch chicken Bucket
from KFC is that even a question at this
point ancient Egyptians also used
exorcism to ward off evil spirits and
one of the most common methods involved
the use of a magic spell called a heca
and this was performed by a priest who
would recite a series of incantations
and make offerings to the gods the
priest would then Place His Hands On The
Afflicted person's head and command the
evil spirit to leave the body the person
would then be given amulets to wear as
protection against future attacks and in
the early days of Christianity exorcism
was an essential part of the faith the
early church believed that demons were
the cause of many physical and mental
illnesses and that the only way to cure
these afflictions was through exorcism
during the Middle Ages exorcism became
even more popular the church saw it as a
way to combat heresy and protect its
followers from the devil's influence
exorcism reached its peak during the
Renaissance when the witch trials were
at their height many people believed
that witches were in League with the
devil and that exorcism was the only way
to rid them of their evil influence the
practice started to decline during the
Age of Enlightenment when people started
to question the church's Authority many
scientists and philosophers saw exorcism
as a superstitious practice with no
scientific basis the church responded by
downplaying the importance of exorcism
and focusing on other aspects of the
faith but exorcism did not Disappear
Completely it continued to be practiced
in many parts of the world especially in
areas where traditional beliefs were
still strong thanks to film and pop
culture and the state of the world there
have never been more exorcists or
exorcisms in history and now in the age
of social media that number is on the
rise once again
exorcism
atic in some form throughout all of
history it was probably the earliest
form of psychotherapy Hippocrates the
father of Western medicine started out
as an exorcist
but is it real
well it depends on your beliefs and what
we consider real do you believe demons
are real if you believe they are and you
believe you're possessed then exorcism
could certainly be a real solution but
if you are cured were demons really
exercised from your body or do you just
believe they were because you believe in
demons
hard to say trying to explain possession
as non-supernatural has been a struggle
for medical professionals for a long
time people claiming to be possessed
show symptoms of epilepsy schizophrenia
multiple personality disorder
disassociative identity disorder bipolar
disorder and many other conditions but
the medications and therapy commonly
used to treat these illnesses often
doesn't work but sometimes exorcisms do
possession is now recognized in the DSM
specifically its possession trans
disorder or ptd but it's a pretty new
addition so modern mainstream doctors
don't think we're dealing with demons
but they acknowledge there is something
happening to some people that they can't
quite explain often people who claim to
be possessed come from very religious
and very troubled homes many times the
possessed are children acting out or
trying to please religious parents for
instance Ronald Hunter the boy whose
story kicked off the modern exorcism
phase he admitted he was baking he said
he was a bad kid acting out against his
mother who was very religious annalize
Michelle's parents were extremely
religious and they raised their daughter
to be as well if Adelis were suffering
from schizophrenia or multiple
personality disorder this could have
manifested as possession something she
was raised to believe was real and
remember annalize was diagnosed with
epilepsy she was also prescribed
antipsychotics when she stopped taking
her meds her episodes got worse now the
faithful will say these conditions were
caused by the demons possessing her
Skeptics will say she was simply
mentally ill and The Possession was just
a manifestation of her strongly held
religious beliefs but nobody can say for
sure Latoya Ammons is also very
religious and extremely superstitious
where most people would consult family
friends or a therapist for advice she
would consult psychics her children were
raised believing that possession was
real and they may have used it to their
advantage it's well documented that over
several years her children missed Allah
out of school the reason they couldn't
go to school they were possessed were
they faking it to stay out of school who
can say also at the time The Possession
started Latoya Ammons was behind on a
rent and she said she couldn't pay
because demons and if you follow this
channel you know that this isn't the
first time someone behind on their rent
claimed it was demons or ghosts the
owner of the house said no tenants who
lived in the house reported anything
strange both before and after Latoya
lived there oh yeah baby what about Zach
the ghost bro I didn't think Ghost
Hunters yeah nothing on that show is
real but it's fun to watch but he
destroyed the house to close the portal
maybe or he demolished the house to
generate some Buzz for his documentary
about the house and knocking the house
down that created some Buzz now inside
Edition with Deborah norfol that portal
to hell that we've been telling you
about in Gary Indiana where so many so
many Eerie things receptive happen
it's been stoled and why do you see
who's moving in the new owner is Zach
Baggins what on Earth were you thinking
buying this house all the witnesses in
that case including police captain
Austin are highly superstitious and
believe in the Paranormal they were
primed to believe the story
they were also interested in money
Captain Austin is on record saying he
thought he might get some notoriety out
of this or even a movie deal and
Reverend magino did get a movie deal he
signed an agreement with Evergreen media
the company that produced The Conjuring
movies which is perfect because the
conjuring movies are based on stories
told by people seeking fame and fortune
there's no truth behind them but true or
not those movies earned over a billion
dollars now I'm not saying all or any of
these people are lying but with stories
like this it's important to see the
whole picture especially when people are
profiting now Believers will say
exorcism is a necessary tool to combat
the force of evil that's all around us
all the time and Skeptics will say
exorcism is a brutal medieval torture
ritual justified by ignorance and people
do die during exorcisms all the time now
you're getting the idea that I'm a
skeptic and maybe I am
but only 90 that 10 of me can't help but
think about father or more I've studied
his life read his articles a couple of
his books he says demonic possession is
real and that he witnessed countless
Supernatural events
I don't think he's lying but actual
demons I look around and I can't find
any proof but evidence of evil well
proof of that is everywhere Supernatural
or not there really is a battle between
good and evil taking place in the world
right now and we all have a role to play
in this battle and knowing this I want
you to ask yourself
which side am I on
[Music]
thank you so much for hanging out with
us today my name is AJ you know
hecklefish ciao bella this has been the
y-files and if you had fun or learned
anything do Heckle fish a favor like
comment subscribe share that stuff is so
helpful and like most topics we cover on
this channel today's topic was
recommended by you and if there's a
story you'd like to see or learn more
about go to the yfiles.com tips special
thanks to our patrons you guys are
amazing and you're keeping this channel
going and if you want to be part of a
great Community Check out the y-files
Discord it's free to join and if you'd
like to support the channel consider
becoming a member on patreon it's as
little as three bucks a month or grab
something from the Wi-Fi store the power
of heckle fish compels you the power of
heckle fish compels you well you're
fired up we're coming a little closer to
my bowl and I'll sprinkle you with holy
vodka I'm in that's gonna do it until
next time be safe be kind and know that
you are appreciated let me grab a class
thank you
[Music]